aux peaux les plus grands paysagistes du
monde entier ont créé une trentaine de
jardins pour le festival de chooz - une
manifestation qui attire plus de cent
cinquante mille visiteurs thomas senécal
et valérie crétins les jardins de
chaumont c'est d'abord une musique la
musique des gouttes d'eau qui rythme la
visite
cette année le thème du festival est
celui des ricochets à l'ombre de ce
château du xvème siècle l'eau fait la
joie des visiteurs en culottes courtes
ça nous envoie plein de choses qu'on
voit pas habituellement c'est pas
commencé
et c'est vrai qu'il ya un peu de tout
dans ces jardins expérimentaux dupont
mystérieux assez drôle de pièges à eau
les enfants vont de découverte en
découverte noir qui se mange
d'accord c'est bon je sais vous laissera
ses plus gros parce que plus là c'est
trop petit
tournesol ou héliotrope ipomées ou
dahlia le plaisir des sens est partout
mais le festival cherche aussi à
inspirer les jardiniers les plus avertis
amusez-vous au pic à nous des idées
donc quand on vous fait une idée c'est
génial pour nous puisque ça nous oblige
immédiatement à la remplacer par une
nouvelle puisqu'on l'adar plus des idées
de jeu les enfants ne manquent pas et
une fois la visite terminée ils sont
unanimes chaumont c'est encore plus beau
qu'un parc d'attractions